g7 leaders are seeking consensus on an
array of issues ranging from trade to
brexit to international security on the
second day of their summit in Barretts
in France but the leaders of the world's
top Western economies are more divided
than ever
French president Immanuel McCoy who's
hosting the gathering has been welcoming
his counterparts to a working meeting
u.s. President Donald Trump and British
prime minister Boris Johnson have
already held their first face-to-face
talks with Trump hailing Johnson as the
right man to deliver brexit the US
president has pledged a speedy free
trade deal if the UK leaves the EU as
planned on October the 31st and EWS
bhavo visa joins us now from the summit
in Biarritz welcome barbara now talks
have been going on for the last few
hours what can you tell us we do have
one first concrete almost concrete
result here that is that the French
president Emmanuel macron has gotten a
mandate from the other g7 participants
to talk to Iran that is not a lot but a
little better than nothing the mandate
says that he is supposed to try and open
diplomatic doors hold talks was around
defuse the tension particularly around
the tanker crisis in the Gulf and
somehow get Iran back into the
diplomatic game so that probably there
can be further down the road talks about
the United States on one side and Iran
on the other side about the future
agreement on nuclear on a new nuclear
deal that is the goal how much macron
can really achieved there who had held
preliminary talks
it was the Iranian Foreign Minister
Zarif before this meeting here is
totally open but at least it is a little
sign of possible peace and de-escalation
on the other hand concerning trade there
is no a wide smoke yet because the basic
difference we know this is Europeans
think that American trade wars are
poison for the world economy and
president Trump ceased
quite differently he says the united
states are doing well our economy is
booming that's his view a perception of
things at least and the rest of the
world doesn't really concern me so
whether there will be any sort of
closing this gap between these two sides
we don't know yet
okay so trade is a fractious issue today
and it's actually something that Boris
Johnson and Donald Trump discussed ahead
of a working breakfast this morning
let's have a quick listen to what they
had to say all right so talk of a
fantastic deal that all seems very
friendly but obviously working out a
trade deal between the UK and the u.s.
is going to be much more difficult than
they're suggesting absolutely all this
is still pie in the sky because every
expert knows that was trade deals the
devil is in the detail first Johnson
came with a quite detailed and rather
special list of the British goods that
he would like to export to the United
States so for instance British pork pie
bell peppers cauliflower shower trays
why he'd choose those Goods nobody knows
but somehow he tries to paint the future
after brexit as a golden era for a
British exports and and British economy
and however he also asked of course for
access to public procurement in the
United States now other people have
tried that before and had no luck
whatsoever and so of course he has to
sort of get up hopes that this is going
to be great
that golden opportunities will arise but
on the other hand everybody knows that
once the two sides sit down at the table
and have to hammer out the details of
this the American side is looking to
their own advantage particularly if
on a Trump is in office and keeping an
eye on negotiations all right these
reporting for us from Barrett's thanks
so much